hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live blitz game somebody 23:58 I
don't think I've ever played this person
before actually let's try a four
sometimes I end up being a fish out of
water with e4 I'm primarily a d4 player
I don't know if I want to go into the
mainline stuff I'm gonna try the Bishop
b5 variation hmm I'm already not sure
what to do I'm just gonna go with simple
development all right I gave up the
bishop pair with this move so if I'm
going to try to show that it was worth
it I'm gonna have to do it quickly try
and show or try and play with being
ahead in development Bishop here is no
good because of a fork maybe I play
Queen back and then play Bishop f4
that's sure Brooke d1 Bishop g5 what
other choices do I have up on e5 pawn e5
pawn takes Knight takes my Knights
hitting his Bishop that might be pretty
good hmm
I'm already getting low on time I better
come up with something quick
um upon ephod if yeah I'll try that
let's retake what my night yeah 90 takes
what does he do here yeah I think he has
to it's selfish up here what do you do
that
I just rook rook on a semi-open file hmm
I think I'm doing pretty good here uh
that move
attacking my rook and my queen I could
take with my knight in my Knights
defending my queen not so sure this is a
good move if I take he recaptures he has
double pawns but then he has play along
the a file
all right I think I'll take where do I
go at my queen next how can I put
pressure on my opponent he still needs
two moves to Castle eventually I'll gain
a temple on his queen as soon as the
rook comes to d1 he has pressure against
a - not quite sure what to do - I just
go for an ending Queen takes rook takes
hmm yeah let's try that let's go for
this
maybe pawn a4 maybe I should develop my
bishop first III g5 to go to g5 you
might come to d5 all right let's go
Bishop e3 Knight might come here then
what I do
if Knight here I can't even make use of
this square they here might be annoying
if Bishop here attacking my knight I'll
probably play Knight d3 hmm he's got
doubled pawns here so maybe there's an
outpost on b4 from b4 none of my piece
it could be chased away I'm gonna try
this Bishop d2 I'm sort of boxing out
his knight by being here my Knights
unprotected so maybe it moved like
Bishop d3 developing and attacking my
knight is a good choice rook f d1 get my
king to f 1e - all right
let's go for this ending I'm gonna
attack his bish up her weight maybe not
maybe I shouldn't pre move right away
pani for attacking this pun
if takes I recapture with my rook I'm
attacking his bishop I think I have to
get rid of one of these double pawns and
I'd still have a two-to-one majority on
the Queen side which is still a an
advantage or maybe I just go go for an
ending trade all the rooks I'll play
here first
93 rook d1 King f1 King E - yeah yeah
I'm gonna go for this rook t1 King f1
see if Bishop here my knight is
conveniently guarding this B 2 square of
course he might play be for now index
this could be a bit cramping - my pawns
b4 and then I really can't move any of
my pawns without isolating them b4 a3
pawn takes pawn takes I'll have two
isolated pawns a file C file this is an
interesting endgame King f1 King e2
seems relevant what does he do here
Castle castle b4 King evil King f1 that
seems sensible
it's an endgame face I get the King
closer to the center
b4 still might be good right maybe I
should have done something about that I
just I just still maybe a3 a3 to stop
before not not c3 because I want my
opponents c2 to be responsible for
protecting my knight but now he's
putting pressure on this so maybe I
should I should go here see I'm gonna
have a nice outpost on b4 now
c3 a 394 okay
I think I'm doing all right this guy is
rated very high for the free internet
chess server 23:58 is quite good care
pawn to e5 is this a blunder I could
just take the knight takes rook here I
don't think I'd be afraid of that I
think that's just a blunder yeah that's
got to be a blunder you five it's a bit
odd
attacking my night and this pond just
retreat here and I'm defending it
alright now this d5 point is a square I
could look forward to placing my knight
on
Bishop retreat I think I'm just a fan of
trading down now yeah I'm a pawn up this
is a weakness rook to d4 if he checks I
just maybe go back to f1 yeah
keep his rook out from the 7th that's
really I'm the only thing I'm concerned
about this Bishop is almost running out
of targets all right I'm gonna fix this
pawn here there's no pawn push g3 to
kick the bishop out rook d5 yeah I'm
doing pretty good here he still has to
worry about back rank threats he's gonna
have to make a flight square first King
all right maybe I should embarrass his
bishop pawn g4 or not just take win
another pot Wow
I'm gonna win this pawn yeah this is
just falling apart for him alright what
to do
support my night with my pawn I'm gonna
come here to here okay
maybe I should have played to the
seventh ranked pawn push I think I'm
doing pretty good here this is this is a
one game it's this is just a matter of
winning this game now rook and pawn
ending I have a bunch of pawns all right
let's see if we could not lose on time
just push my pawns I think
well I'm getting ready to come here
alright let's just secure my 7th rank I
don't want him to grab my b2 pond
advance my king
you really can't do anything pawn here I
just push and I have a passed pawn now
his rook is tied down he's gonna work
himself into a pin takes and now rook
here alright I still have this yeah
give a check just play here next
threatened rook trade threaten come here
push my pawn come here
maybe we'll just go after this pawn here
yeah yeah this is a one game I'm not
liking my technique though seems like
there was an easier way don't go about
winning this game I'll just cut his king
off
Brook here - here
and just advance these pawns now
a little pretty long time okay hopefully
this guy isn't too fast
all right drop my rook get his rook back
Wow well that was a very tight game
rating and commenting as always I
appreciate it thanks so much bye